foreign
do you know what the realm is
it's the Thousand Blades of aegon's
enemies a story we agree to tell each
other over and
you forget that it's a lie
what's up ladies and gentlemen welcome
back for another Game of Thrones
in-house of the Dragon update video in
this new video I will be discussing a
major bombshell that was released in
regards to why one of House of the
dragon show winners and directors
actually stepped away from the show now
as I'm sure most of you already know
Miguel is a Game of Thrones veteran most
famously known for directing some of
television's biggest episodes like
hardhome Battle of the bastards The
Winds of Winter and even the long night
after Miguel had directed episodes like
hardhome and battle of the bastards I
think it was safe to say he secured
himself as the number one Game of
Thrones director throughout the fandom
this was something HBO noticed which was
a large reason why they fought so hard
to get him back for the final season of
their most successful show when HBO and
George R Martin were developing House of
the Dragon Miguel was once again an
obvious candidate to bring on board
because he had so much success with the
original Game of Thrones series now that
David and Dan were gone from Game of
Thrones HBO not only hired Miguel is a
director for House of the Dragon but
they also brought him on as one of its
showrunners along with Ryan Condell I
immediately thought this was amazing
because now Miguel could really bring
his vision to life without having to
worry about David and Dan interfering
with his work now that he was one of
House of the Dragon showrunners he found
himself at the head of the operation of
one of the biggest shows in history this
was a match made in heaven if you go
back and watch all of my videos when
this news was first announced I was very
excited because I knew how much Miguel
had elevated Game of Thrones since Ryan
was a student of A Song of Ice and Fire
I knew he would be able to adapt George
RR Martin's novel with a certain amount
of accuracy and with Miguel working
alongside him I knew he would be able to
help bring it to life on the screen
better than almost anyone else working
in television I mean it really is no
wonder how so the dragon's first season
had so much success the men and women
working behind the scenes were a
well-oiled machine firing on all
cylinders so you can imagine how Dev
devastated I was when I found out Miguel
was stepping down as one of its
showrunners before the first season had
even ended at first it didn't make sense
why he would want to walk away from a
major hit series I was actually shocked
when I heard this news although I
shouldn't have been because I did know
Miguel already had issues at HBO when he
was working under David and Dan now if
you remember back in August shortly
after House of the Dragon aired its
first episode we found out Miguel was
leaving the show that article stated
there's been a big shake up inside house
of the Dragon the HBO fantasy dramas
co-showrunner and director Miguel
sapochnik is stepping down from the hit
show they were basically saying Miguel
was leaving due to exhaustion from
working on House of the Dragon well
thanks to the new information that has
been released we now know that wasn't
the case there was some drama behind the
scenes at House of the Dragon involving
Miguel's wife who also worked on the
show now before I get into all of that
let me remind you of what girl said back
in August when he initially said he was
leaving the show he said working within
the Game of Thrones Universe for the
last few years has been an honor
especially spending the last two with
the amazing cast and crew of House of
the Dragon I am so proud of what we
accomplished in season one and Overjoyed
by the enthusiastic reaction of our
viewers it was incredibly tough to
decide to move on but I know that it was
the right choice for me as I do so
though I am deeply comforted to know
that Alan will be joining the series
he's someone I've known and respected
for a long time and I believe this
series could not be in safer hands I am
so glad to remain a part of the HBO and
House of the Dragon family and of course
I wish Ryan Condell and his team's
success in all the best was season 2 and
Beyond so as you can see there was no
real mention of why he was leaving
although another source said it was due
to exhaustion well now let me show you
what really happened behind the scenes
at the show in a stunning new article
released by Indie wire their headline
States Miguel left House of the Dragon
after HBO would not allow his wife to
serve as one of the show's producers now
all of you have actually seen his wife
before because she was an actress in
House of the dragon as well let me show
you what else was said and I will tell
you why I actually side with HBO
although I am a massive fan of Miguel's
work no show on television has more
family drama than House of the Dragon
HBO's soap opera about the Game of
Thrones Targaryen Clan fighting for
control of Westeros and that drama
apparently isn't just on screen
according to new reports about The
showrunners of the hit series shortly
after the first season aired back in
August co-showrunner Miguel sapochnick
announced he was leaving the show though
he would continue to Executive produce
the series HBO and Miguel framed his
exit as the amicable one however
according to the new information
Miguel's exit was far from Amico Bowl
the new information says that his leave
from the show was instead motivated by
disagreements with him and HBO over his
wife Alexis Rabin and her involvement in
House of the Dragon his wife Alexis was
in four episodes of the series as Talia
a lady in waiting to Allison Hightower
and she is credited as a producer on
season one of the show it looks like
Miguel was then again asking for his
wife to be included on the producing
team for the show's second season only
for HBO to refuse they did this because
of her inexperience her only producing
credit is on season 1 of the series you
can actually see that on her IMDb now
the article also says that HBO had to
bring in a mediator to de-escalate the
situation because things got so heated
Miguel ultimately decided to leave the
show over the disagreement firing his
agents at WME before going to the Rival
agency CAA with his wife so not only did
Miguel and his wife step down from House
of the Dragon but they also also fired
their agents and joined forces with
their Rivals obviously things must have
been very ugly behind the scenes
especially for Miguel to want to walk
away from such an incredible opportunity
the reason why HBO did not want to hire
his wife is because she did not have the
experience Miguel was basically wanting
her to be given that role simply because
she was his wife I must say I do agree
with HBO on this one they are learning
from their mistakes we already saw what
happened with David and Dan after they
no longer had George RR Martin's novels
to follow their inexperience became a
major issue for the show Once they no
longer had anything else to fall back on
I don't blame HBO for standing their
ground now I don't think Miguel's wife
would have had a major effect on the
show either way since she wasn't a
writer or director but I still don't
think she should have been given that
job over someone else who knows what
they're doing and I would say the same
thing if the genders were reversed for
example I think Lena Headey was one of
the greatest actor in Game of Thrones
and I would not want her husband
standing around messing up scenes just
because of his association with his wife
HBO did decline to comment on the story
to Indy wire now before joining season 1
of House of the dragon as co-showrunner
alongside Creator Ryan Condell who will
now serve as the sole showrunner of the
series Miguel directed six episodes of
Game of Thrones starting in season 5. on
House of the Dragon he directed the
first and the seventh episode drift Mark
in a story with The Hollywood Reporter
before the series aired Ryan Condell
admitted that Miguel was hesitant to
join House of the Dragon telling him I'm
never doing Game of Thrones again this
was all because of the issues he already
had while working under David and Dan so
we were actually lucky to have him on
House of the dragon at all now with that
being said I guess if one of the
showrunners did have to leave I would
rather it be Miguel although I do think
he is an amazing director I think they
are a lot easier to find than someone
like Ryan condo the reason why I believe
Ryan is so valuable to House of the
Dragon is because he's the one who
actually knows George RR Martin's story
he has at least read it and studied it
far more than David and Dan ever did I
would argue either way it is unfortunate
that Miguel did have to step down I do
respect him for standing beside his wife
but I also don't blame HBO for standing
their ground either it just sucks that
things had to get so messy we may never
see Miguel direct another episode in the
Game of Thrones Universe again now I
know him and kid Harrington are really
great friends so maybe he could convince
him to direct an episode of Jon Snow's
show if it ever gets made but outside of
that I don't see Miguel directing
anything else relating to Game of
Thrones at least we now know the real
reason why he wanted to leave the show
let me know what all of you think about
this leave me some of your thoughts down
below now for those of you who don't
know I am giving away the First full
season of House of the dragon all you
have to do to enter is make sure you're
subscribed I wanted to announce the
winner in my next video which would have
been this one but since it hasn't even
been 24 hours since I made that
announcement I will wait until I release
another one that way more of you are
aware of it so good luck and thank you
for showing Love by watching and
interacting with my videos I hope all of
you have a great day I will see you
again very soon
bye
[Music]
[Music]
foreign